maintenant sur la sphère des poursuites
maquis de serre nous avons un cabinet
qui se présente comme un cabinet
patriotes qui vient au secours du
gouvernement français dans la crise
sanitaire que nous avons connus qui
vient apporter ses moyens éventuellement
gratuitement comme d'autres cabines à
d'ailleurs elle pas le seul au début
puis ensuite vous avez 18 commandes qui
suivent bien évidemment avec des
montants je crois ça doit être de
l'ordre de 13 millions mais vous
retrouverez les chiffres pour maquiller
pour le seul mckinsey puisque ses 41
millions en tout pour la crise sanitaire
donc un cabinet qui se présente comme un
recours patriotique en quelque sorte
dans son intervention
et qui nous dit texto mais bien sûr nous
sommes une société de droit français
nous payons tous nos salaires en france
et nous payons l'impôt sur les sociétés
en france nous avons examiné cette
situation sur pièces et sur place avec
madame la rapporteure il apparaît que
depuis dix ans cette société n'a pas
payé l'impôt sur les sociétés et elle ne
l'a pas payé c'est une nuance importante
parce qu'elle a systématiquement produit
des résultats fiscaux déficitaires
depuis dix ans vous pouvez aussi avoir
des sociétés qui ne paient pas l'impôt
sur les sociétés mais quand un résultat
fiscal positif mais qui se trouve minoré
par différents crédits d'impôts
notamment le crédit impôt recherche que
vous avez dû connaître et puis le cic le
crédit compétitivité qui n'existe plus
maintenant ça aurait pu aussi expliqué
jaune c'est pas le cas dans ce cas là
c'est systématiquement du résultat
fiscal négatif tout ça c'est lié c'est
peut-être un peu près le membre de la
commission des finances qui parle mais à
la mécanique des prix de transfert en
fait c'est ce que refacture la maison
mère aux états unis à la succursale en
france
c'est évidemment prévues par les règles
du commerce international de l' ocde le
tout c'est de savoir si c'est appliquer
loyalement et valider ou pas par
l'administration française ça maintenant
c'est à la direction générale des
finances publiques de le dire parce que
s'occupera de cette question dû
commencer à s'en occuper mais en tout
cas nous ce qui nous a choqués c'est le
fait que monsieur tadjeddine nous disent
en audition nous payons impôt sur les
sociétés en france et que quand on
regarde
dix dernières années cet impôt est à
zéro et l'état zéro parce que le
bénéfice fiscal est systématiquement
mais le résultat fiscal pardon est
systématiquement négatif voilà donc nous
allons en référer au procureur de la
république et ce sera à lui d'apprécier
la situation
[Musique]